is it just me or does it feel like the
only way you and i can save the world
from climate change or global warming is
by owning a tesla or an electric vehicle
as if if we drive gas or diesel the
world is coming to an end matter of fact
we just recently saw president biden
talk about the fact that by 2030 50 of
all cars need to be evs and even newsom
talked about the fact that by 2035 a
hundred percent of the cars need to be
evs but the story is deeper than that
the more we research the more bizarre
god with china with congo with cobalt
with lithium with child labor very
bizarre but we're going to get right
into it in today's episode
so stick around colavarian to get the
pdf of what we're talking about today
but there's a few questions that we have
to answer number one the argument for
having evs and the argument against it
number two which industry will benefit
the most from evs number three who is
hurt by evs number four are evs the new
diesel scandal waiting to happen and
then some final thoughts on today's
discussion so first things first there's
a lot of good motives here people are
concerned younger generation climate
change global warming but is it really
worth it here's why because when we look
at the total
u.s greenhouse gas emissions by economic
sector in 2020 this is what it looks
like 29 is caused by transportation 25
is electricity 24 is industry which is
raw material we all use 13 is commercial
and residential 11 is agriculture but
this is the key today's focus is
transportation and out of the 29 only
16.82
of it is cars so the question becomes is
the 16.82 the cars everything let's
change everything up 20 30 20 35 is that
worth the shift that we're making today
to fully understand that we have to look
at some numbers here's some numbers to
look at in regards to total cars sold in
q4 of 2021. in q4 of 2021 we sold little
over 3.3 million cars in the us of which
only 152 000 were diesel 353 000 were ev
and then the rest which is about 2.761
million are just regular gasoline cars
and by the way for some of you just to
show you how new this is
we've only been selling evs roughly
since 2010 tesla who is the main leader
in this market has only sold
1.917 million 450 cars and fyi since
2016 to the first half of 2021 they've
sold roughly a third of all evs in
america okay so now that we saw some of
those numbers let's look at the argument
between having an ev versus not having
one so price wise if you want to buy an
ev today the average ev today is roughly
56
437 versus the average gasoline car is
forty seven thousand seventy seven
dollars according to kelly blue book so
if you look at the numbers right there
it's only a ten thousand dollar
difference but if you do buy an ev you
get a seventy five hundred dollar tax
credit on the back end from the
government so maybe it's not up front
but you are getting it on the back end
now let's take a look at miles when it
comes onto miles let's compare two cars
i drive an f-150 so let's look at the
f-150 that's gas versus the f-150 that's
ev which is called the lightning so if
we were to look at the regular f-150 it
would cost you
99.31 to fill up the gas tank that's at
an average of 4.32
but if you had the lightning it would
only cost you 13.48
to charge the battery so what does that
number break down to here's what it
looks like on the f-150 the regular one
it comes down to 20 cents a mile versus
the lightning it comes down to six cents
a mile that's a big savings nearly a
third of the cost for regular gas now a
few things if you're on the ev you have
no emissions no gas less maintenance of
course you're gonna have to change the
tires and the basic things but when it
comes down to the ev they can pretty
much update on their own you know
software updates gonna happen regularly
you don't need to do an oil change you
don't need to do all the other stuff
that you go
to a mechanic for you don't have that
with the ev which saves you a lot of
time so now so far you may say oh my god
pat you already sold me i'm gonna go buy
an ev tomorrow i'm buying a tesla
tomorrow matter of fact i'm going online
to order tesla before you do hang tight
hear the entire argument the complete
opposite side says the following number
one
if you have a car that's a regular car
going off of gas you can find gas
stations pretty much everywhere now if
you drive an ev and you're going on a
road trip good luck finding a charging
station because that's
spotty at best and on top of it many of
them that you may find maybe not even
working one of the questions we asked on
twitter we said what's your biggest
argument against evie one guy commented
and said i am an ev owner i drive my car
but half the charging stations are
broken and it's frustrating for an owner
next when it comes down to tesla the
makeup of a typical tesla owner is a
six-figure earner who's making money who
can afford to finance a 57 000 car with
tax and everything included even though
you're getting the 7 500 on the back end
don't forget you need to finance the
whole thing up front so you need to make
money to be able to buy an ev like a
tesla so at this point in the game you
may say pat you still haven't changed my
mind i'm still getting an ev and i'm
sticking to it no problem there's two
things you need to know about the
current evs that they're producing you
need lithium and you need cobalt okay to
produce the evs that they're producing
now what's the big deal about lithium
let me explain to you over a single year
producing 60 tons of lithium at the site
could mean digging up as much as 20 to
30 million tons of earth yes earth like
if you look at the picture right there
that's earth you see that big hole we
need to do that to get 60 tons of
lithium more than the annual amount of
earth dug up to produce all coal output
of all but seven or eight u.s states
that's pretty insane to think about
hauling the material wait for this one
will require 75 tractor trailers loads a
day
every one of them running on ready
fossil fuels and this doesn't include
the excavators the diggers any of that
other stuff and it doesn't include the
transportation of the employees going
there i'm just giving you the basics of
lithium here now let's take a look at
cobalt when it comes down to cobalt
reserves we have roughly 7.6 million
worldwide of which
you have countries like usf 69 000 china
80 000 madagascar 100 000 canada 220
russia 250 philippines 260 cuba 500 000
indonesia 600 000 australia 1.4 million
you ready
democratic republic of congo
3.5
million tons of reserves of cobalt which
by the way 15
out of the 19
mines in congo are owned and operated by
china let me say that one more time 15
out of 19 are owned and operated by
china which by the way they bought this
land in africa nearly two decades ago
which is a massive bet that they took
thinking one day this you know people
say oh this is such a visionary this got
such a visionary two decades ago is 2002
2002 nobody driving teslas but in 2002
they kind of said we may be going in
this direction that cobalt nobody looks
at cobalt and looks at us as anything
you've seen ceramics of cobalt we don't
wake up one morning and say we need to
go by cobalt right that's what they did
15 out of 19
which if you were to look at the dna of
china and you were to say what would
their motive be
maybe they're thinking about not selling
the cobalt to others maybe they're
thinking about producing the cars that
need cobalt because the world has to buy
the cars from them it's a form of a
monopoly isn't it if we go in that
direction gotta give them credit for
making a decision like that but at the
end of the day
that in itself could lead to something
where other countries are relying on
china
to get cobalt from them just like the
world has been relying on china to get
ships and many other products that we
felt during covet according to human
rights organization amnesty
international the growth has put
pressure on miners in the drc to ramp up
production leading in turn to tens of
thousands of children being lured or
forced into grueling and dangerous mind
work you know sometimes when we're
trying to solve a problem you you're
like well yeah we have to do this
because we got to get away from fossil
fuel and then when you really look it up
and you put the map together like wait a
minute to get to where we want to get to
we have to make some some kind of
sacrifices so no let's not do fossil
fuel because god forbid global warming
and you know everything climate change
that we're going through but yeah let's
do lithium and take 20 to 30 million
tons and dig up from the earth well
that's pretty bad if we keep doing that
yeah how about we go get cobalt and we
get through china 15 to 19
mines they own and 50
plus of it isn't there so we have to go
through congo and they got a monopoly
and we got to get away from cobalt
but we still got to do it but how about
the child labor oh my god so what do we
should we go this direction or not it's
a very conflicted bizarre
decision processing that we're going
through so there's not really a we're
making the right decision we're not
making the right decision it's very
complex but let me continue so the next
question is which industries will
benefit from evs so the first one is
battery manufacturers obviously this is
going to be very big for them because if
this is the direction that we're going
to
companies that develop batteries for evs
are said to see huge upturn in adoption
of these vehicles worldwide matter of
fact if the sale of evs continue at the
anticipated rate a study suggests a
total of 60 billion dollars worth of
batteries will need to be produced to
cater to this demand so that's one
industry is going to take a massive
massive profit from this direction that
we go to number two is ev manufacturers
which is pretty obvious you got tesla
and anybody else that's producing evs
they're going to see a mate this is why
tesla's valued at nearly a trillion
dollars and have only sold 1.9 million
cars that's pretty insane to see numbers
like that and then you have transport
you know where there's transport public
transportation they're going to have to
convert to that because it's less
maintenance less headache of course the
cost of getting it up front is going to
be more but it's going to be less
headache and you know maintenance on the
back end and last but not least is
utility providers as more drivers opt to
install an ev charging point at home
their energy usage will inevitably
increase in fact predictions suggest
that the average household energy
consumption will double with the
installation of an ev charging point so
the next question is who will be hurt by
evs
many will say big oil however even if
electric vehicles come to entirely
dominate the transportation space exxon
mobil is expecting little change in
global oil use
the oil major predicts that oil use for
transportation will decline slowly but
overall oil demand will continue to rise
as crude is needed for industry and
petrochemicals
here's what a spokesperson from exxon
mobil said if every car sold in 2025 was
an ev leading to every single passenger
vehicle in the world being an ev by 2040
the global demand for oil and gas would
be the same as it was in 2010. they
won't even feel it but who will feel it
is going to be that small little
business owner that owns that gas
station in the corner you know who i'm
talking about you go to mobile exxon
whoever it is not exxon but some of
those guys that own that franchise they
will feel it because that's eventually
going to go away so for those of you
that drive diesel you may want to skip
this next part because the decision you
made to get diesel this may offend you
so brace for impact are electric
vehicles the new diesel scandal waiting
to happen
so bjorn lombard the author of false
alarm wrote an article for daily mail
which was titled are electric cars the
new diesel scandal waiting to happen
he says do you remember britain's dash
for diesel it began more than 20 years
ago and then chancellor gordon brown
announced a new car tax system favoring
vehicles with lower emissions of carbon
dioxide the greenhouse gas that
contributes to global warming diesel
cars tend to be more fuel efficient with
lower emissions and mr brown held them
as greener and cheaper option over a
decade and a half the number of such
vehicles on british roads quadrupled
what happened
what didn't emerge until much later
although it was no secret in a motor
industry or among government officials
was that diesel cars also emitted
greater quantities of other pollutants
nitrogen oxide and particulates that
damage air quality in human health
such particulates which have been linked
to respiratory problems heart disease
and lung cancer have been responsible
for thousands of premature deaths
britain wasn't alone of course in their
desire to be seen as ever greener
governments of richer countries were all
pursuing the same policies on car tax or
cutting duty on diesel fuel so what's
the moral of the story none of us know
this thing is going to work or not
nobody knows diesel they took a big bet
in britain 20 years later they realized
maybe it wasn't the right bet that we
took it didn't work it backfired if u.s
their cars is only 4.6 diesel 50 of cars
in europe is diesel let me say that one
more time ten times more than u.s cars
in europe one out of every two cars
diesel they all bet on this diesel thing
they don't work for them watch
what
someone said about the direction we're
going with evs the international energy
agency iea estimates
that if every nation achieves its
ambitious targets on increasing electric
car
electric car ownership it will reduce
co2 emissions in this decade by 235
million tons which means what according
to the un climate panel standard model
will reduce the global temperature by 1
10 000
of a degree celsius that's point zero 0
0 1 celsius by the end of the century
so is it really worth it
so i'm curious if you want to see more
content like this give us a thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel if you do
want to get today's content in a pdf
click over here to get the pdf and if
you want to see another video similar to
this i did a video titled climate change
myth or reality if you haven't watched
it click over here to watch that video
take care everybody bye
you